- Eugene, drink!
- You choose
all of these bottles. Up!
- It worked.
(laughs)
- Yep, that's Koreans for ya.
(upbeat music)
- We love soju.
- So I've had soju before,
but not flavored soju.
- Soju is dangerous.
It's smooth, it's watery.
- I take pictures a lot
when I drink soju.
- When you're on soju?
- Yeah.
- If you like sweet and
you like fruity flavors,
you might like this
more than me, actually.
(piano riff and upbeat music)
- I love peach.
- This is how Koreans drink.
Because I'm 27
- Wow.
- And he's 28.
If we were out drinking and I was like...
- That would've so turned me on, though.
(laughs)
- We gonna be a little turnt.
- [Both] Jjan!
- It tastes just like peach rings.
I'm so into it.
- Oh, that's not even alcoholic.
- It's probably a little
too sweet for you, right?
- Yeah.
- You could feed this to children.
Wait, don't do that.
(upbeat music)
- So when you pour soju for people,
if they're older than you,
you have to use two hands to pour.
So you're older than I am.
- To us.
(glasses clinking)
- Uh, this one tastes a lot
like Fresca, like a soda.
- That tastes like Sprite.
- I do, like, very clearly
see how I could drink
a whole bottle of this
and not realize how silly I'm getting.
(upbeat music)
- How do you eat grapefruit?
- With a little bit of salt and a spoon.
- Oh, so you cut it in
half and spoon it out?
- How do you eat grapefruit?
- Like an orange.
- Huh.
- This smells delightful.
- This could be a candle.
- Hmm.
- Mmm.
- That was good.
- That's incredibly good.
That is not alcohol.
- I don't like grapefruits
and I don't know why I
thought I'd like this.
(laughs)
- This seems like the closest
to the actual flavor of the food.
- These taste like melted
popsicle concentrate flavor
that you would know from ice creams.
- What types of ice creams are you eating?
- A sorbet.
(silly upbeat music)
- Oh, this one smells awful.
- I smell blueberries.
- I love...
The women on these.
Chan!
- Chan!
- That smells like cough syrup.
- Uhhh. Blueberries should
not be mixed with soju.
- That's not good.
- It does not taste like blueberries.
- Ooohh.
- Now this tastes like kids medicine.
- Ned.
- It's a straw.
- How does that taste?
- It tastes like liberty.
- This one sucks.
(Beep) blueberry flavor.
(upbeat music)
- No no no.
- This is how it's supposed to be.
I'm pretty sure.
- I'm sorry Korea.
- Perfect, got it.
- Smells tropical.
It feels like I'm in Malaysia right now.
- Gamsahabnida! ("Thank you!" in Korean)
(glasses clinking)
- Woah.
- Just a little too sweet for me.
- That has a bad aftertaste;
that's the problem.
- It's like pineapple that was left
in a cup of water overnight.
- This pineapple is amazing.
You're just continuing to drink.
- She's like juice baby.
- You know what's
confusing about pineapple?
- It's not made of pines or apples?
- Woah!
(ukulele strumming)
- Oh, God.
It smells even more like
fruit punch than the last.
- This is like when you
go to the dentist office
and they're like, "What type
of flavor would you like
"on your gas mask?"
And I'm like, "I'll take red please."
- This is straight up melted Starburst.
How did they distill this?
- It is a pretty subtle
flavor but I like that.
(upbeat music)
- I've never been a huge
fan of flavored sojus
because I feel like it's
just drinking juice.
- Yeah.
- I like my liquor
to taste like liquor.
- It's designed for like my little sister
and Steven Lim.
- I bet he's having a great time.
He's probably being way too loud.
(screaming)
I bet he's like ohhhhh!
- Alright, drink up!
- Koreans need to take
over the taste making.
- Cool things about people in Korea:
really fast internet, hot
girls, really good soju.
Get at me.